the ceasefire appeared to collapse
almost as soon as it was brokered Israel
said it's Iron Dome rocket defense
system intercepted several launches with
most others falling into open fields
earlier in the evening a rocket aimed at
the border town of de Raadt got through
defences and destroyed a home no
casualties were reported the tit-for-tat
attacks were triggered by a rocket that
have litter ated a residential home
outside Tel Aviv in the early hours of
Monday Israel said that rocket was
launched by Hamas the militant group
that rules Gaza the homes residents were
awoken by air-raid sirens and managed to
flee before the rocket crashed through
the roof and exploded this is the real
price and I just played it and I nearly
lost my family and if we hadn't have
booked to the bomb shelter in time I
would now be burying all my family by
nightfall the Israel Defense Forces were
retaliating with rocket attacks striking
targets in Gaza hideouts they say of
Hamas militants
the ceasefire reportedly broke it by
Egypt and accepted by Hamas late on
Monday was never confirmed by Israeli
officials the rocket attacks through the
night show that if it ever really
existed the ceasefire is at best shaky
and at worst over before it even took
hold let's cross over to our
correspondent Tanya Kramer who's
standing by with the latest in Jerusalem
Tanya one side in this conflict says a
ceasefire is in place what can you tell
us yeah that's true they were already at
10 o'clock last night local time reports
of a ceasefire being brokered by Egypt
and Hamas put out a statement that Hamas
and the other militant faction would
adhere to a ceasefire and would meet
quiet for quiet meaning that Israel
would hold as air strikes also rocket
attacks into southern Israel would be
halted from the militant factions but it
went on a couple of hours but for the
last two three hours since to early
morning actually it has been quiet is
this obviously attempts quiet and we
have to wait and see how the next hours
here will develop now Egypt has in the
past already brokered successfully
ceasefire so it seems to be the case at
this time as well whether it will hold
is another question
Tanya stay with us we're going to come
back to you in just a minute we first
want to take it another take a look at
another development the cross-border
violence comes as the United States
reverses decades of policy in the Middle
East by officially recognizing the Golan
Heights as Israeli territory
US President Donald Trump trailed the
decision on Twitter last week during a
visit by Israel's Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu in Washington Trump
signed a proclamation calling for
recognition of Israeli sovereignty over
the territory now the Golan Heights are
an area of strategic importance in the
Middle East
the occupied Golan Heights are a
mountainous plateau overlooking Israel
Lebanon Syria and Jordan until 1967 the
Golan Heights belonged to Syria during
the six-day war Israel captured and
occupied the territory after the
arab-israeli war in 1973 a UN observer
force has been deployed to monitor the
ceasefire line and a separation area
between the two sides
Israel's annexation of the Golan Heights
in 1981 was never recognized by any
other country until the US did so last
week UN Security Council resolutions
called for a withdrawal and declared
Israeli sovereignty null and void
pending negotiations with Syria several
attempts to negotiate an agreement went
nowhere today around 40,000 people live
there about half hours railey settlers
and the other half are Druze an Arab
minority who mostly consider themselves
Syrian the plateau is higher elevations
offer military advantages Israel's
military can look deep inside Syrian
territory if Syria held the Golan
Heights his forces would enjoy a
commanding position over northern Israel
the hilly area just next to the Sea of
Galilee is also an important water
source after the Syrian civil war
started in 2011 the security aspect of
the area has become even more important
Israel says that Iran and its Lebanese
Ally Hezbollah both supporting the Assad
regime have entrenched themselves close
to Israel's boundary so let's go back to
Tanya Kramer now in Jerusalem
Tanya president Trump has decided to
unilaterally recognize Israel's
sovereignty over the Golan Heights was
this move widely expected and how could
it affect security in the region in
Israel at least there had been
indications that the US administration
would lean towards recognizing Israel
sovereignty so that was expected but the
tweets still last week on Thursday from
president from came a bit as a surprise
it was warmly welcomed here by all
parties that have been part also of the
election campaign even of mr. Newton
competitors there is a consensus in as
well that this charity territory should
stay Israeli territory some had said you
know this was an interesting timing
because there is an election campaign it
was an election gift also by mr. Trump
to mince mince mr. Netanyahu could say
that he has such good relations with the
US administration and you know those
leaders are very close but at the same
time of course there has been also a lot
of criticism across the region of this
decision it is against international
laws against UN Security Council
resolutions and us is together with
Israel the only country recognizing the
occupied Golan Heights as Israeli
territory Tania good talking to you
there thank you for bringing us
up-to-date DWS Tanya Kramer in Jerusalem